No.
When you were in Alberta,
you went back to that place that you were talking about on the first podcast we
ever did,
where you had that encounter,
where you shot that elk that was just outside of that wolf den and the wolf's
tried to claim the elk.
Yeah,
I just had a shoot your way out of there.
Yeah.
Is a fucking crazy story.
What was it like to be back there again?
Um,
it was,
what was strange about it is while we were there,
uh,
I actually found that they were back in that area.
Um,
there was some fresh tracks and then we heard one how like during that thing.
So it was almost like,
it was a little bit weird because,
um,
did you guys bring an extra bolts this time?
We only had my bow this time.
I'm sending you this Jamie.
Oh,
Geez.
Um,
but,
uh,
yeah,
the,
the thing that,
um,
the thing that was always kind of creeped me out a little bit was just,
it was,
I felt like I had like kind of a personal connection with that Alpha male
because of the way when,
you know,
he came in at the very end cause he wanted to know what the heck had taken out
three of his pack.
He wanted like,
it's almost like he's like,
I know we're getting out of here,
but I want to see this for myself because,
you know,
they were close enough but I don't think they could totally see us.
So as that was going away,
um,
grizzly,
yeah.
It tells him look like a brown or a black bear though in the nose.
Yup.
See how the face is more narrow.
So yeah.
And then the cost to Yup.
Yup.
Yeah.
Which like on the right foot,
the claw looks more like a black bear on the left foot.
There was some grass there that made it a little bit strange.
But,
um,
when that Alpha male came in to kind of,
you know,
I think he just wanted to know,
okay,
what's caused all this,
this stuff?
So,
you know,
I looked at,
I looked him in the face and just pretty much said I'm going to shoot you in the
face.
Um,
I always,
every time I go back in that area,
I'm like,
you know,
this old suckers walking around,
he knows my smell.
He's probably going to be like,
there's that.
Yeah.
I personally,
they are smart.
I could picture him remembering it and saying,
okay,
oh,
this,
I owe this.
Do I owe this dude?
And then make him into a hero.
He turd on the side.
Yeah.
I sent you that,
uh,
that Wolf Big Wolf Shit that had porcupine quills all that.
I put that on Instagram.
It's funny how many people were like that.
That is not porcupine.
Quills it's like,
listen,
people,
I'm in the outdoors 200 days,
probably a year.
And if there's porcupine quills coming out of a pile of Shit,
I'm pretty sure I did.
I know
what it is.
It's hard to tell from a photo
on my Instagram.
Jerry,
here we go.
It's a,
a pile of shit with porcupine quills in it.
Imagine how God damn
hungry you have to be to be eaten.
Porcupine quills and swelling going wolf's that tough.
He doesn't care.
It's like a bear.
Look at how many bears just,
we'll just go head first into a pile and like a fire ant bed or a or a wasp ness
like yellow jacket.
It is make that a little bigger please.
Down in the bottom you can see some nice quills.
Yeah,
yeah.
Some people would go though.
It's her.
And the other is there is porcupine here in their correct.
But those are also quilts.
There's,
there's a couple of blood drops up there.
It needs some prep age.
Um,
how are we,
yeah,
they're,
they're obese.
They're beast.
That is,
you know,
I th I think,
I think their intelligence,
their intelligence level is,
is super high.
I think a lot of,
you know,
the more you're in the outdoors and you experience things demeanors and their,
uh,
their ability to survive.
You know,
you look at,
uh,
one of the,
you look at an old grizzly that's been in those woods for 20 years,
think of the experience level that thing has surviving every single day.
I mean,
every day just maybe making a slight mistake,
slipping up a little bit,
almost getting jacked by another grizzly and then you're like,
oh,
Yep,
I know not to do this.
I know not to do that.
I mean,
they're there until their intelligence level and their ability to function is
extremely high and wolves are,
I mean,
arguably wolves probably get shot less than probably any of the other animals.
they're,
they are incredibly smart.
So,
yeah,
I wouldn't,
I wouldn't doubt it.
You know,
it was,
um,
and they're,
they,
they were very,
after that,
um,
intent in that area for people to,
they put up some pretty big bounties on the wolves and they really went after
him and,
and knock those herds down quite a bit because there was very few mule deer,
like very few mule deer,
you'd hardly see a doe and Fon.
They had to cut the number of tags way down,
uh,
elk as soon as wolves.
Like how at night if a pack moves into an area and they how like calling elk is
just nonexistent.
They just,
everything's just like,
don't say nothing cause you know,
they're here.
Um,
so yeah,
I think,
I think them thinning them down was,
was very relevant.
And since then,
which was quite awhile ago,
um,
the numbers of like elk and Moose,
like this past year,
I saw way more moose than I've seen.
Um,
I think they're really hard on Moose Fonz.
and yeah,
I mean,
Moose Mulally's white tails.
I saw way more animals this year than in the past up there.
And I think it's just because that Moose number or the wolf number was just much
lower.
Um,
but there was,
like I said,
there was still signed that there was some in the area,
just nothing.
Like several years ago when I was there,
it was,
you know,
it was even,
I would say,
as much as I appreciate balance in nature,
it was excessive and it's getting that way now.
Like even in Wisconsin,
I remember I was talking to a friend of mine up in an area I used to live up by
kind of in the Lacrosse area,
actually lived a little northeast of Lacrosse by a small town called cataract.
And there was a few times where there was some wolf spottings.
Um,
there is a big military base here called Fort Mccoy and I lived up on the
northern side of the base,
um,
what was called the impact area.
They kind of shot test rounds over and they kind of went off there or whatever,
but there was an incredible number of like deer and things that were in there.
So,
you know,
kind of the rumor was that they had introduced wolves into their timber wolves
to let,
to kind of thinned down some of those numbers will now it's to the point where
the amount of people I know in Wisconsin that sea wolves is just rapidly
increasing.
And obviously when that happens,
you know,
they eat stuff.
I mean,
wolves don't mess around,
they take stuff down and sometimes it's just strange.
You don't understand the balance of um,
of why there's an introduction to something that,
you know,
has the possibility to just take over.
You know,
it's,
it's strange.
Well,
it is,
but it's also,
there needs to be some sort of balance.
You don't want the animals overpopulating and you do want some sort of a balance
between Predator and prey.
But the real problem becomes when people don't want to manage the predators,
right.
They only want,
they want nature to sort itself out.
Yeah.
This is,
it doesn't really work that way though.
I mean,
it's just people need to understand,
like if you do like deer and you like Mousse and you like all these other
animals,
you can't have too many wolves cram too many.
Yeah.
You can't have too many grizzlies because if you do,
you're going to have very few of those other animals.
You're not going to see them.
They're going to get wiped out.